[Música]
a economia criativa bom vocês sabem que
a economia criativa
primeiramente vamos pensar como se a
economia criativa para ajudar as
crianças a fazer a diferença no futuro
então vamos lá a economia criativa não
posso definir apenas um papel ela pode
ser definida e utilizadas de vários
papéis com ajudar as pessoas a trabalhar
melhor talvez conseguir mais recursos de
vida fazer as empresas evoluir e
melhoria nas indústrias
agora eu vou dar dois exemplos de duas
empresas criativas a mesa catarse em 3d
financiamento coletivo que faz com que é
projeto que ficarem no papel possa
receber doações de pessoas comuns e
virar realidade
já a empresa doente ela não só queria
camisetas com estampas divertidas como a
cada uma vendida desta ser uma segunda
que adora ter uma instituição de que
essas tarefas
agora vou mostrar um vídeo pra vocês e
tentei um pouquinho melhor sobre
economia criativa
[Música]
a economia criativa ajuda as pessoas se
conectarem e gera renda e crescimento
sustentável e agregar valor e
competitividade em que produtos serviços
como é concluindo como disse no começo
na palestra como velha economia criativa
para ajudar as crianças a fazer a
diferença no futuro bom
muitas pessoas falam que as crianças não
são os nosso futuro né
será que isso é verdade espero que eu
tenha esclarecido um pouco sobre
economia criativa e algumas idéias de
como poderá ajudar essas crianças fazer
a diferença no futuro
obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]